knocking on one door one don opens it
and just grabs the by the way and pulls
her in
come out
[Music]
i've been friends with these two guys
for a couple years after meeting them
at the start of college and summer last
year we reconnected after the first
lockdown restrictions had been eased
over this time i had been in a
relationship however
when me and the lads saw each other
again
me and my man had split we all got
really close again and one night me and
the guys went out
the same night i introduced my best
friend to them and we formed our own
little friendship group so it's two
girls and two guys at this point right
yeah i'm following i'm there one of the
guys and my girl really hit her off
i kind of started seeing each other okay
and me and my other friend car
did um started a friends with benefits
ting okay
i should mention that even though me and
my man had split
we were still sleeping together on a
regular here we go
of course i've been to my friend's
benefit house once and we started
getting down to it
but my man's stuff was just not my man
stuff was just not working oh
i thought that maybe he was uh just a
bit rusty
and didn't think too much of it the four
of us decided to stay at my girl's flat
for a weekend and therefore
was gonna be another chance for me and
him to get down to it
bearing in mind my man had been hyping
this weekend up to the max
dangerous dangerous
guys always take that risk in it you
hype it because
you believe it of course you believe it
of course ah
right the time came that we were going
to get down to it and
the second time around yeah this is the
second time around we're getting down to
it my man
came before i'd even really touched it
oh i was disappointed but didn't want to
make him feel bad so we just left it
awkwardly the first thing that came to
mind was to message my ex to see if he
was awake
so that maybe i could get some form of
satisfaction
but he was asleep the next day i was
icked to the max by him
but i still had another night to spend
with him oh god
oh this is torment so i purposefully
fell asleep on the sofa before everyone
else
we drove home the next day and i've not
really spoken to him
since am i the [ __ ] oh
deary me that was actually a far more
enjoyable read than i anticipated
oh that's so peaked he must have been
pulling his hair out devastated
absolutely devastated
but i don't necessarily think she's the
[ __ ] purely because
one um yes he was hyping it up
but it's understandable i think any
human being would hype up that situation
um she wasn't sexually satisfied so you
can't really
sometimes when women well not sometimes
most times when women aren't sexually
satisfied
they're going to get a bit like
frustrated in it and it's it's normal
it's absolutely normal he was livid if
it was me and you
and then we got two things to a yard
this this happened to me and i
first night i couldn't get up second
night at night before she even touched
it third and i slept on the sofa
and you were just clapping cheeks
everyone's going home
everyone's going home i have to tell you
fam
you need to sort out tonight when she's
asleep on the server i say wake her the
[ __ ] up
let's go let's go he he should be
his friend's the [ __ ] yeah his friend
should have coached him through that uh
because to be fair yeah because they
would have spoken out for sure he would
have to i spoke about
i fumbled the bag again and she's
falling asleep on the sofa and i just
been
busting nuts bro i would have told you
fam
listen i would i would have grabbed your
hand
to the chest i was like come on big man
like through head
look at you you're a beast fan come on
i'm so i'm vexed because obviously we're
just thinking about these three nights
but i'm thinking
these men had to spend the day together
the whole days what the [ __ ] did they do
in the daytime did when they're all at
the dinner table having food
because obviously she's told her girl
and obviously i've told my boy i've told
you basically everyone knows
everyone knows everyone everyone knows
that i'm a flop i'm literally a flop
you're the joke of the weekend you're
the joke of the cottage
oh my god that man are cuddling in the
next room and you're in the bed
i'm in a basement all alone yeah you
stepped in the bed alone alone just
all you can hear is the wind whistling
vexed and then the next day we just
drove home in silence
nah she's living she probably you could
say oh i beg you drop me off on my ex's
yard
imagine just drop me here just mention
she just dropped me and you're like
what this where's there you just see her
knocking on one door
one don opens it and just grabs her by
the waist and pulls her in ah
number two come out i can do
better it would have to be manhood i can
imagine it like a scene from the office
because you know they've got a camera
tick where they always look at the
camera
so she she knocks she knows she comes in
and the camera goes to my man
zooms into my man he looks like the
camera he looks at us
grabs her smiles and closes the door
and he winds the window up and dries off
and then it pans to
the bedroom in the front seat and he's
gym
they're just priming gyms that's not my
business class
we united last night oh no that's
hilarious thank you for that
everything you have as a man rides on ah
that's fixed that's vexing i would be so
annoyed thank you for that one
thank you for that because that's that's
made my day that's made my mind
the long story short no you're not the
[ __ ] because you did what you had to
do you did what you have to do
um you did give him a second chance he
flopped the second chance
um i understand sexual frustration so
i'm not even mad at the fact that you
message your ex because it happens like
you said but you've learned a lot more
about females sexual frustration during
this podcast
or from this podcast rather so yeah it's
it's it is what it is man you tried to
get your nut you clearly wanted it from
him he didn't give it to you so boom
he's lost in it he's definitely he
should have he should have spoke up
he should have